das ist ein livebild aus wien aus der
parteizentrale der vp der
österreichischen volkspartei und auf
dieser bühne an diesem pult wird
sebastian kurz der große politische
überflieger in wenigen minuten das ende
seiner politischen karriere verkünden
nachdem er erst im oktober als
bundeskanzler zurückgetreten war wird er
jetzt auch sein amt als parteichef in
niederlegen bei uns im studio ist paul
ronzheimer der sebastian kurz gut kennt
sebastian erst sebastian sage ich schon
paul paul was wird ihnen dazu bewegt
haben jetzt auch komplett alle ämter
abzulegen sebastian kurses zu der
erkenntnis gekommen dass seine
politische karriere zumindest vorerst
vorbei ist denn die vorwürfe gegen ihn
da geht es ja um manipulierte umfragen
um bestechlichkeit gegen ihn und sein
team müssen vielleicht noch mal daran
erinnern es geht um vorwürfe aus dem
jahr 2017 die durch sms verkehr
hochgekommen sind vor ein
umfrageinstitut bessere werte ausgegeben
haben soll als es tatsächlich war das
ganze ist jetzt wieder hochgekocht und
da gibt es ermittlungen jetzt ist noch
völlig unklar ob es eine anklage gibt ob
er bei einer anklage dann auch
verurteilt würde aber das ganze dauert
zwei bis drei jahre schätzt man und bis
dahin will kein koalitionspartner und
wollen auch große teile offenbar
mittlerweile der vp nicht dass er noch
einmal antritt für die partei der
immunität wurde ja auch aufgehoben das
war ohnehin klar also dass das passieren
würde weil es ja die ermittlung blieb
das war keine aktuellen das war keine
überraschung allerdings ist es so dass
ihm eben die zukunftsvision die zukunft
oder zu sein dort weiterzumachen
momentan nicht gegeben ist also eher
kann wenn der kandidat würde keine
koalition mehr form weil die spd andere
mögliche koalitionspartner sagen würden
moment mal es gibt diese ermittlung ist
hat sich nichts verändert und da scheint
sebastian kurz jetzt auch die luft
ausgegangen zu sein dann weiterhin
vp-chef zu bleiben es gab zuletzt aus
tirol vom landeshauptmann kritik der von
ihm abgerückt ist dass sie es waren der
genau die ministerpräsidenten das heißt
immer mehr auf widerstand in den eigenen
reihen und sebastian kurz hätte da jetzt
weiterkämpfen können ich glaube er hätte
auch eine chance gab bei der vp chef zu
bleiben jetzt ist ja am wochenende aber
vater geworden also will sich sozusagen
auch mehr aufs private konzentrieren und
gleichzeitig möglicherweise dann in die
wirtschaft wechseln allerdings eins muss
man sagen ein politisches comeback ist
nicht ausgeschlossen wenn die vorwürfe
sich den aufklären in zwei drei vier
fünf jahren waren auch immer wenn er
freigesprochen würde schließe ich nicht
aus sondern halte es sogar für sehr
möglich sehr wahrscheinlich dass es
zumindest versuchen wird ob das klappt
ist noch eine andere fragen halte man es
hat gerade gesagt du kennst ja auch
persönlich er hat ihnen diese
entscheidung wird ihm trotzdem schwer
gefallen sein heute
er war in einem prozess des nachdenkens
schon in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten und hat auch über diese
verschiedenen optionen nachgedacht also
was kann er tun die hoffnung war auch
dass die umfragewerte der svp nicht so
sehr abfallen würden das auch seine
persönlichen werte stabil bleiben würden
das ist nicht eingetreten
die svp steht momentan bei rund 26
prozent was im vergleich zu dem was man
mal hatte weit über 30 ein sehr
schlechter wert ist das heißt er hat die
erkenntnis immer mehr gewonnen dass er
sozusagen dort momentan nicht rauskommt
dass momentan keine chance gibt für ihn
auch wieder nach vorne zu kommen weil
egal was er versuchen würde ja alle
sagen moment mal hier ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft eventuell gibt es
eine anklage das sind schwerwiegende
vorwürfe und da parallel politik zu
machen ist eigentlich unmöglich jetzt
wir uns doch noch mal ganz kurz paul
diese karriere in österreich der jüngste
außenminister zunächst mit 28 jahren
dann der jüngste bundeskanzler in europa
da war der welt der welt das ist eine
absolute überflieger karriere gewesen
jetzt der rasante absturz
erzählen uns noch ein bisschen bringen
uns sebastian kurz noch mal näher eine
absolute wahnsinns karriere so was den
kurs in der jungen cvp ist sozusagen der
vergleich zu jungen union an gefangen im
jungen alter wurde dann schon mit 24
staatssekretär damals
integrationsstaatssekretär in der sp vp
regierung dann immer weiter aufgestiegen
unter dem damaligen parteivorsitzenden
ist er dann außenminister geworden wurde
dort weltbekannt kann man sagen durch
die situation hier sehen wir ihn auch
noch mal
durch die situation die es gegeben hat
um den balkan route um die
flüchtlingskrise hat sich in
konservativen kreisen als der gegen mann
als die gegenposition zu angela merkel
immer mehr positioniert wurde so immer
bekannter und konnte dann am ende ja in
seiner partei die macht gewinnen er hat
es geschafft durch jugendlichkeit durch
ausstrahlung durch rhetorik das waren
seine ganz großen stärken und eben durch
einen stramm konservativen kurs
insbesondere flüchtlings gleichzeitig
bei flexibilität werden wir hier auf das
live-bild schauen wo etwas bewegung
hineingekommen es könnte sein dass er
jeden moment kommt aber gleichzeitig
auch ein höchstmaß an flexibilität muss
man sagen vorher mit der
rechtspopulistischen fpö
koaliert und dann zack bumm mal eben
eine 180 grad wende und eine koalition
mit den grünen geschmiedet ja das hängt
alles zusammen mit der ib zur affäre und
man muss sagen auch dieser rücktritt
jetzt hängt noch mit der ibiza affäre
zusammen wir erinnern uns damals heinz
christian strache heimlich gefilmt
worden gibt es eine serie mittlerweile
auch bei sky und dann über diese affäre
gestürzt und im zusammenhang mit dieser
affäre wurde ein handy oder wurden daten
sichergestellt von einem engen
vertrauten von sebastian kurz oder einem
vertrauten und früheren vertrauten
thomas schmid der im finanzministerium
gearbeitet hat und der auf sein
mobiltelefon alle whatsapp sms
gespeichert hatte gegen den wurde damals
nur ermittelt und im zuge dieser
ermittlungen sind dann ist dann die
staatsanwaltschaft auf und unter anderem
diese umfrage mögliche umfrage sache
gestoßen wo ihm eben und seinem team vor
allem der bestechlichkeit manipulierte
umfragen vorgeworfen wird also alles was
danach in österreich im zuge passiert
ist auch um sebastian kurz hängt an der
überzahl fähre da ist dann damals nur 1
strache gestürzt und danach hat er mit
den grünen weiter gemacht nur dann jetzt
im oktober konnten die grünen nicht mehr
weitermachen und haben gesagt es reicht
das muss ein neuer bundeskanzler her das
hat der alexander schallenberg der
außenminister übernommen der dort ist
über trauer von sebastian ein vertrauter
von sebastian kurz genauer hat mit ihm
im außenministerium gearbeitet ist dann
rüber in ghana oder abend
nämlich jetzt hier antritt und davon
einmal reinhören
sehr geehrte damen und herren wenn man
auf einen prägenden lebensabschnitt
zurückblickt und im blick zurück trotz
aller herausforderungen die das leben so
mit sich bringt vor allem eins empfindet
nämlich dankbarkeit dann glaube ich darf
man sich sehr glücklich schätzen ich
stehe heute hier vor ihnen und
darf auf zehn jahre politische tätigkeit
in der österreichischen bundesregierung
zurück blicken zunächst der
staatssekretär dann als außenminister
und zuletzt das bundeskanzler
und um ehrlich zu sein bin ich für diese
zeit extrem dankbar für all diese
erfahrungen die ich machen durfte für
alles das uns gelungen ist und ich hoffe
natürlich sehr dass ich meinen beitrag
auch leisten konnte unser wunderschönes
österreich ein kleines stück in die
richtige richtung zu bewegen
zumindest habe ich stets mein bestes
gegeben und alles versucht ich
habe von anfang an und sie haben das als
medienvertreter das ja genau beobachtet
aus meinen politischen überzeugungen
keine geheimnisse gemacht dass ich
arbeiten gehen in österreich auszahlen
muss und dass jeder der arbeiten geht
auch von seinem einkommen leben können
muss das migration nicht ungestört
stattfinden darf sondern es auch grenzen
braucht und dass wir einen starken
wirtschaftsstandort brauchen damit wir
auch den wohlstand in unserem land
aufrechterhalten können all diese
überzeugungen und klare positionen die
haben zustimmung aus und gleichermaßen
natürlich auch ablehnen und ich sagte
dazu ich glaube dass das wichtig ist in
einer liberalen demokratie auch diese
debatten zu haben und ich habe den
diskurs zu all diesen themen persönlich
eigentlich immer sehr geschätzt
ich durfte in dieser unglaublich
intensiven zeit sehr viel lernen denn
die politik ist extrem vielseitig und
gerade die aufgabe als bundeskanzler
bietet eine extreme inhaltliche breite
vor allem aber bedeutet
spitzenpolitik und sie können sich das
wahrscheinlich denken vor allem auch
stetig ein wechselbad an gefühlen zum
einen ist es wunderschön wenn man etwas
bewegen kann und wenn man das gefühl hat
etwas zu tun dass man für richtig
erachtet
gleichzeitig ist es aber so dass man
jeden tag so viele entscheidungen zu
treffen hat dass man schon in der früh
weiß dass jeden tag auch falsche
entscheidungen dabei sein werden und
darüber hinaus steht man unter ständiger
beobachtung wird täglich kritisiert und
hat fast ein bisschen das gefühl gejagt
zu werden und es wird sie vielleicht
überraschen aber
sogar diese eindruck gejagt zu werden
hat eigentlich auch etwas positives
ausgelöst das hat mein team und mich
stets auch zu höchstleistungen motiviert
mein team und ich haben in den letzten
zehn jahren fast rund um die uhr
gearbeitet wir haben alle die aufgabe
die funktion die tätigkeit für die
republik über fast alles andere gestellt
und haben natürlich somit in den letzten
zehn jahren extrem viel zeit investiert
ich gebe zu es war für fast alles andere
eigentlich kaum oder gar keine zeit und
viel es ist in dieser phase
wahrscheinlich auch nicht entsprechend
möglich gewesen und manches ist
vernachlässigt worden insbesondere die
eigene familie
in den vergangenen wochen die nicht
einfach waren und dann in den
vergangenen tagen sehr schön waren
insbesondere auch bei der geburt des
eigenen kindes ist mir dann aber mehr
und mehr wieder bewusst geworden wie
viel schönes und wichtiges es auch
außerhalb der politik gibt
und
was mir ganz besonders wichtig ist
festzuhalten ist dass ich überzeugt
davon bin dass es das eine ist für eine
politische tätigkeit 100% zeit zu
investieren das ist eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit in so einer
funktion
ich glaube was ist vor allem aber auch
braucht ist mit 100% begeisterung dabei
zu sein mit begeisterung dabei zu sein
und auch freude an der tätigkeit zu
haben und ich kann ihnen nur sagen ich
für meinen teil ich war die letzten zehn
jahre mit 100-prozentiger begeisterung
dabei und ich hatte immer enorme freude
an der politischen arbeit die letzten
monate die letzten wochen die letzten
tage ist diese begeisterung bei mir ein
bisschen weniger geworden das hat sich
verändert und ich glaube nach einer so
langen zeit ist es durchaus auch ein
natürlicher prozess das begeisterung
weniger wird in meinem fall haben
sicherlich auch die entwicklungen der
letzten monate stark dazu beigetragen
ich habe politik immer verstanden als
einen wettbewerb der besten ideen und in
den letzten monaten war aber mein
politischer alltag kein wettbewerb der
besten ideen mehr sondern viel eher die
abwehr von vorwürfen von anschuldigungen
von unterstellungen und von verfahren
und
meine leidenschaft für politik die ich
zehn jahre lang hatte sie ist sicherlich
in dieser phase auch ein stück weit
weniger geworden
und auch wenn es vielleicht dazu gehört
in solchen spitzenpositionen immer
wieder mit vorwürfen zu kämpfen zu haben
und ich weiß aus dem inland von vielen
kollegen und vor allem auch aus dem
ausland von vielen anderen
regierungschefs dass das für viele
normalität ist vorwürfen ausgesetzt zu
sein aber wenn man es selbst erlebt dann
ist es doch etwas kraftraubendes etwas
zählendes und es hat zumindest innen
meine eigene flamme ein bisschen kleiner
werden lassen
mir ist wichtig sehr geehrte damen und
herren
festzuhalten
dass und ich hoffe sie verstehen mich
nicht falsch ich möchte ich möchte heute
nicht behaupten dass ich nie etwas
falsch gemacht habe ich habe immer mein
bestes gegeben aber ich habe
selbstverständlich
fehlentscheidungen getroffen ich habe
immer wieder in gewissen momenten es
auch nicht geschafft meinen eigenen
ansprüchen gerecht zu werden
aber
gleichzeitig möchte ich in aller
deutlichkeit sagen ich bin weder ein
heiliger noch ein verbrecher ich bin ein
mensch mit stärken und schwächen mit
fehlern und erfolgen und allem was sonst
noch dazu gehört und gerade weil es
vorwürfe gegen mich gibt die seit
einigen monaten im raum stehen ist mir
wichtig auch noch einmal festzuhalten
ich freue mich persönlich auf den tag
auch wenn es jahre dauern kann wo ich
bei gericht auch beweisen kann dass die
vorwürfe gegen meine person schlicht und
ergreifend falsch sind
die heutige entscheidung und das können
sie sich wahrscheinlich vorstellen
sie ist mir nicht leicht gefallen aber
ich sag dazu es ist trotzdem so dass ich
keine schwermut empfindet denn ich bin
extrem dankbar für alles was ich in den
letzten zehn jahren erleben durfte und
ich bin auch froh über all das was
meinem team und mir für österreich
gelungen ist mit 35 jahren darf ich
jetzt zurückblicken auf mittlerweile
zehn jahre dienst an der republik auf
unglaublich viele eindrücke erlebnisse
und erfahrungen auf begegnungen mit
unglaublichen persönlichkeiten vom dalai
lama bis zum papst gespräche mit dem
präsidenten der weltmächte usa china und
russland
die vertiefung unserer beziehungen mit
unseren freunden am westbalkan was mir
immer ein besonderes anliegen war das
schmieden von allianzen auf europäischer
ebene um die schulden union zu
verhindern oder um für mehr
subsidiarität einzutreten
und meiner meinung nach auch die
notwendige auseinandersetzung mit
unserer geschichte und der versuch ein
noch besseres verhältnis mit dem staat
israel aufzubauen und auch
innenpolitisch haben wir es denke ich
geschafft einige vorhaben zu
verwirklichen die mir immer ein großes
anliegen waren die einführung des
familienbonus und eine steuerliche
entlastung für familien die co2
bepreisung um eine schrittweise
transformation auf unseres steuersystems
sicherzustellen oder auch
modernisierungsschritte die wir gesetzt
haben die kritisiert worden sind wie die
flexibilisierung der arbeitszeit und
andere wo ich glaube dass sie wichtig
für unseren wirtschaftsstandort waren
zuletzt ist natürlich alles im fokus der
pandemie bekämpfung gestanden wo wir
stets versucht haben neben der
gesundheitlichen aspekte auch mit
wirtschaftsinstitut um das
wirtschaftliche und das soziale leid das
durch die pandemie ausgelöst wird so gut
wie möglich in grenzen zu halten
was mir immer am meisten freude bereitet
hat das war quer durch österreich
unterwegs zu sein und mit menschen aus
ganz unterschiedlichen ecken und
denkrichtungen zusammenzutreffen und das
schönste gefühl war eigentlich wenn
einem menschen ihre ganz persönlichen
sorgen und nöte geschildert haben und
man wusste man kann nicht nur zuhören
sondern man hat als politiker die
möglichkeit die dinge zumindest ein
stück weit für diese menschen in die
richtige richtung zu verbessern das ist
uns gelungen ist kleine portionen
endlich ein stück weit zu erhöhen dass
es uns gelungen ist kleinere einkommen
und familien zu entlasten
das ist etwas was mir
extrem wichtig war und wo ich einfach
auch überzeugt davon bin dass das die
ehre meines lebens war und ist und an
das werde ich mich auch immer erinnern
oft heißt die politik ist ein
undankbares geschäft
und mir ist wichtig am heutigen tag
festzuhalten dass ich das überhaupt
nicht so sehr und ich möchte dem auch
entschieden widersprechen ich halte es
für
unglaublich schön sich für etwas
einsetzen zu woran man glaubt es ist
unglaublich schön für die eigene
republik für das eigene land arbeiten zu
dürfen und diesem dienen zu dürfen
und auch wenn die politik ein robustes
geschäft ist keine frage so ist es doch
so dass im gespräch mit den menschen
quer durchs land man als politiker immer
auch sehr viel zurückbekommt und
daher sehr geehrte damen und herren
stehe ich heute nicht nur sehr dankbar
dafür diese zehn schönen jahre sondern
ich möchte natürlich auch die
möglichkeit nutzen und ich hoffe sie
gestatten wir das und alten menschen
danke sagen ohne die dieser ganze weg
und all das niemals möglich gewesen wäre
ich möchte mich vor allem bei meinem
team bedanken weil ich die möglichkeit
hatte tagtäglich mit herausragenden
menschen zusammenzuarbeiten
ich möchte mich bei den ministerinnen
und ministern in meinen regierungs
mannschaften bedanken die allesamt
tagtäglich großartiges leisten ich
möchte mich bei unseren
koalitionspartnern fpö und grüne
bedanken denn trotz aller unterschiede
und ja die gibt es ist es immer
eigentlich gelungen relativ
professionell zusammen zu arbeiten und
mit vielen gab es auch auf menschlicher
ebene stets eine gute basis ich möchte
mich bei bundespräsident van der bellen
und nationalratspräsident sobotka
bedanken denn das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit dass der auftritt
im ausland für die republik stets gut
abgestimmt war und gerade in
krisenzeiten war auch immer eine gute
zusammenarbeit im inland gewährleistet
und ich möchte mich bei alexander
scheinberg bedanken weil ich selbst weiß
was es bedeutet verantwortung zu
übernehmen und er war bereit vor einigen
wochen in einer schwierigen zeit
verantwortung zu übernehmen
ich möchte mich natürlich
ganz besonders bei der volkspartei
bedanken die mich stets getragen und
unterstützt hat meiner politischen
heimat der jungen övp den ländern und
bünden für die geschlossenheit in den
jahren den generalsekretären stefan
steiner elik köstinger axel menschen
haben wir die tolle arbeit geleistet
haben ich möchte mich bei denjenigen
bedanken die mich schon sehr früh
unterstützt haben als ich noch nicht in
der öffentlichkeit gestanden bin in der
jungen svp von markus figl bis josef
pröll michael spindelegger war es dann
haben wir eine chance staatssekretär
gegeben hat kann nämlich leitner hat
mich damals in dieser für mich sehr
schwierigen phase als 24-jähriger zu
beginn in der regierung sehr unterstützt
und natürlich möchte ich auch all jenen
danke sagen die mich immer mit ihrer
lebenserfahrung
unterstützt haben und ganz uneigennützig
mir stets mit rat und tat zur seite
gestanden sind das sind sehr viele
stellvertretend für viele möchte ich
hier vielleicht wolfgang schüssel und
andreas khol nennen vor allem aber sehr
geehrte damen und herren gilt mein dank
den wählerinnen und wählern und den
unterstützerinnen und unterstützern wir
haben zwei wahlkämpfe nicht nur führen
sondern auch gewinnen dürfen und das
wäre niemals möglich gewesen ohne die
zehntausenden unterstützerinnen und
unterstützer quer durch österreich
und ich war mir eigentlich immer sicher
dass diese beiden wahlkämpfe durch
nichts zu toppen sind ein paar tagen
habe ich dann erlebt dass die geburt des
eigenen kindes noch einmal alles andere
top was man je zuvor gesehen oder erlebt
hat so ein kleines baby kammer stunden
lang anschauen und ist froh und
glücklich darüber und insofern ist
natürlich dieses wunder etwas
einzigartiges aber abseits dieser
persönlichen freuden im privatleben sind
diese zwei wahlerfolge sicherlich etwas
was ich niemals in meinem leben
vergessen werde wo ich danke sagen
möchte und noch ein leben lang eine
große freude darüber empfinden werde
wenn ich heute den abschied aus der
politik nehme dann möchte ich noch
einmal betonen und das ist mir als
obmann der volkspartei wichtig dass ich
überzeugt davon bin dass es wichtig ist
dass es eine starke volkspartei gibt die
grundwerte der volkspartei fleiß
eigenverantwortung aber auch solidarität
die haben einen beitrag dazu geleistet
dass unser land heute so lebenswert ist
wie es ist und wie möchte an dieser
stelle auch klar sagen dass gerade weil
von manchen immer wieder der eindruck
erweckt wird als wäre der erfolg der
volkspartei auf eine person oder auf
meine person in den letzten jahren
zurückzuführen kann ich ihnen nur sagen
dieser eindruck ist falsch es gibt in
der volkspartei unglaublich viele
erfahrene kräfte es gibt viele junge
talente und es gibt ganz viele menschen
die quer durch die gemeinden auf
landesebene vor ort oder auch auf
bundesebene das feuer auch in sich
tragen dass sich zehn jahre lang hatte
und sie tagtäglich sich bemühen
bestmögliches für unser land zu leisten
ich bin überzeugt davon dass es auch in
zukunft eine starke volkspartei geben
wird die gute arbeit für unser
wunderschönes österreich leisten wird
und ich werde um das auch zu
unterstützen morgen eine sitzung des
bundesparteivorstands einberufen und
werde meine funktion als obmann
übergeben ich werde die leitung des
clubs wieder an gust wirkung über tragen
der das schon jahrelang hervorragend
gemacht hat und ich werde in den
nächsten wochen eine geordnete übergabe
an meiner politischen funktionen
sicherstellen für mich sehr geehrte
damen und herren
beginnt somit ein neues kapitel in
meinem leben dass ich mit heute
aufschlagen darf
vor allem freue ich mich darauf einmal
zeit mit meinem kind und meiner familie
zu verbringen und ich werde das sehr
genießen bevor ich dann auch persönlich
im neuen jahr beruflich mich neuen
aufgaben widmen werde ich gebe zu ich
stehe heute da und bin nicht nur
gespannt auf diesen neuen
lebensabschnitt sondern ich freue mich
auch darauf aber mir ist wichtig zu
betonen
es war mir eine große ehre der republik
zehn jahre dienen zu dürfen vielen dank
[Musik]
also meine damen und herren das war also
sebastian kurz mit 25 24 25 jahren in
die politik gegangen mit 35 jahren legt
er alle ämter nieder und verabschiedet
sich aus der politik was für eine
karriere paul ronzheimer werden
persönlich kennt ist bei uns im studio
paul ja eine außerordentliche karriere
die rede jetzt zum schluss war dann
allerdings ich will ich sagen pathetisch
aber ja auch ein bisschen feierlich
weinerlich habe ich sie nicht empfunden
ich glaube schon dass es emotional
natürlich für ihn ist dass politik war
sein lehrer aber eher harmlos ganz kurz
er hat dann den einsatz gesagt ich bin
weder heiliger noch verbrecher für mich
eigentlich einer der entscheidenden
sätze also er hat einerseits sozusagen
fehler eingeräumt
andererseits gesagt dass er weiter dazu
steht dass er nichts falsch gemacht hat
im strafrechtlichen sinne das wird sich
herausstellen was da wirklich passiert
ist oder was dort nicht passiert ist
darauf wird man warten müssen aber er
hat auch gejammert paul hat gesagt ich
muss immer so viele entscheidungen
treffen und dann steht man immer unter
beobachtung und dann wird man gejagt wir
haben aber rund um die uhr gearbeitet
und jetzt hat man mir die freude an der
arbeit genommen durch die vorwürfe kann
man als jammern bewerte ich sie ist ein
bisschen anders ich glaube einfach dass
es sehr aus seiner sicht oder seiner
persönlichen perspektive wenn er
sozusagen dazu steht dass er
strafrechtlich
sich nichts vorwerfen lassen was er
nicht getrennt hat oder was man
kritisieren kann ist aus meiner sicht
das natürlich ist neben der
strafrechtlichen komponente auch eine
politische komponente gibt also etwas
wenn man sich diese sms anschaut dann
natürlich ein bild entstanden ist in der
öffentlichkeit über ihn das nicht
übereinstimmen mit dem wie er sich
gegeben hat vorher absolut das ist
richtig nur es ist jetzt so dass wenn er
nach so vielen jahren aus der politik
geht das natürlich für ihn ein
emotionaler moment ist noch mal ich
glaube es muss nicht für immer sein so
gut kenne ich sebastian kurz ich glaube
dass das ein kluger zug ist es raus zu
gehen weil er könnte nichts mehr dort
momentan hinbekommen könnte nicht mehr
noch einmal zurückkommen als kanzler
momentan so lange diese für dich
aufgeklärt sind 25 jahren versuchen
andere noch nach dem sinn im leben nach
einem job oder wissen noch nicht was sie
machen sollen ist er in die politik
gegangen mit 35 hört wer zumindest
vorläufig aus vielen dank für die
einordnung an diesem bedeutenden tag für
österreich kann man schon sagen